in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit. Amen.
Though reading, from the Sinaxadion, for September 25th, on which we commemorate,
the Great Earthquake at Constantinople in the year 447, and of the Miracle of the Trisagion.
On the 25th of the month, we celebrate the commemoration of the Great Earthquake at Constantinople
in the year 447, and of the Miracle of the Trisagion. In the reign of Emperor Theodosios II,
the years 408-450, God, Bountiful and Rich in Mercy, caused the ground to shake dreadfully
for almost four months to warn Christian people to be always ready, for the great day when the
dead shall be raised. Heaven and Earth shall be changed into a new form, and every man shall be
summoned to judgment upon the righteousness of his faith and the purity of his life.
Fear gripped the entire city. The Emperor, the patriarch St. Prokhrus, and all the people
of Constantinople, went in procession barefoot to the parade ground of Hebdomon, where they made
earnest prayer to God for their safety. About the third hour, the ground once more began shaking,
and a young boy was suddenly taken up into the skies by the strength of the Almighty,
while the terrified people cried, Kirie Eleison, with redoubled fervor. When he came down from
on high, the child declared he had been taken up amid the choirs of angels who were singing holy
God, holy mighty, holy immortal, have mercy upon us, and that a voice had commanded him to tell
the patriarch that the people ought to make their supplications to God in this way, without adding
anything. The patriarch instructed the chancers and people to intone this hymn that joins confession
of the three divine persons to the cry of the seraphim in the vision of Isaiah, where upon the earth
stopped shaking, and the child gave up his soul to God. The most pious Empress, Polkhria,
and joined St. Prokhrus to order this hymn to be solemnly chanted henceforth in the liturgy.
At the Holy Council of Calcedon in the year 451, the fathers, from the Roman diocese of Asia,
greeted the proclamation of the true faith by chanting the Trisagion, which has since
become an essential element in the private as well as in the common prayer of Orthodox Christians.
When Peter the Fuller, the usurping patriarch of Antioch, wanted to spread the poison of the
Theopaschite heresy, a type of monophysism, he had the expression who was crucified for us,
added to the thrice holy hymn, circa the year 468. The Orthodox remembered that when the child
was miraculously taken into heaven, the divine voice had distinctly forbidden any addition to the
hymn, and they strove hard to maintain the trinitarian understanding of the Trisagion against a
Christological interpretation. So by right glorification of the one only God in three persons,
the Orthodox faith was kept through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ,
our God, have mercy on us and save us.